foreign
python is one of the emerging
programming languages according to the
most recent figures python is the most
used coding language for about 80
percent of developers the syntax of this
high level programming language is
simple to understand pythons large
Library System makes it a best choice
for data science machine learning and
artificial intelligence projects so
hello Learners welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel and today we will be
doing financial analysis using python
but before we begin if you love watching
Tech videos subscribe to our Channel
like the tutorial and hit the Bell icon
to now miss an update and let us have a
simple quiz question to brush upon our
knowledge and your question is which
keyword is used for function in Python
language and your options are
your first option is function and second
option is
DF
third is f u n or fourth is defined you
can pause the video give it a thought
and answer in the comment section below
and we will update the correct answer in
the print command and there's an
insightful for you guys if you are
focused on building strong foundational
skills for career growth in that case
you can check out a free course to Learn
Python Basics with the completion
certificate from scale up by simply
learn you can also check the python
Basics free scale up course Link in the
description below and with this we'll
start our tutorial first we'll create a
folder to do the financial analysis
first we'll go to our python projects
and this is our data on which we would
be doing the financial analysis
and I will provide you the link in the
description box for this sheet also so
this sheet indicates that the genders
male and female how they invest and what
stage their investment in mutual funds
Equity Market debentures government
bonds and fixed deposits
and at how much duration and how they
invest daily monthly weekly so we would
be doing financial analysis on this
sheet so starting with
first we'll create a folder
and name it as financial
analysis financial analysis yeah I was
going to make a spelling mistake but I
didn't
so here we would open up Jupiter
notebook in which we're going to proceed
with our financial analysis you could
use any idle you want to use I would be
using the Jupiter notebook for that I
will open the command prompt and write
the command
Jupiter notebook
and we'll get our Jupiter notebook open
in the browser
till then it's loading
we would
move a CSV file
into a folder only
financial analysis
so it would be easy for us to do
some tasks like
we can easily provide the link for the
CSV file
now moving to a Jupiter notebook we have
Finance underscore data.csv in a folder
now we'll create a new file
and Name It We Will name it as
binance analysis
now starting with
the first thing we should do is import
our libraries or import our modules and
first module we would be using would be
numpy
and we would be importing that and to
install that you could just simply
go on the folder
call the command prompt and write pip
install
numpy
you can easily find these
commands to install any module on the
web or you can just see like what I
would be installing and you could see
that the requirement is already
satisfied as I have already installed
the numpy and all other module that
would be using in in this tutorial
so you could just go to the command
prompt and write the command and the
module would be installed for you
now
we would move back to our Jupiter
notebook and start importing our
packages
and the first package we have seen the
command to install it and now we will
import it that would be numpy an import
numpy and use the Lis as NP and the
second package would be importing would
be pandas for that we'll write the
command import pandas
and we will also use the Allies here and
use SPD and you can install the pandas
Library by using the command pip install
pandas or you could just simply search
on the web you would get the commands
there also so I'll run this command uh
it's showing the abstract mark That's
clear that our commands have been run
successfully so moving on now you would
see uh how many files are present in a
folder in which we are making this
python notebook
so for that we will first import the OS
module and you can simply install it by
using the command that would be pip
install Os or for OS it would be pip
install sys uh hyphen OS so you could
simply search on the web
or I would show you
I would open an incognito window for you
and
pip install
OS
python
so you could see this is the official
website for
OS module you could simply visit on that
and you could simply copy the command
that is OS
iPhone sys and just open the command and
paste on your command prompt it would be
installing your command easily or you
could also paste that command into a
Jupiter notebook it would do the same
task for you now we want all the files
that are present in our folder so for
that we'll write
four
directory name
comma
underscore comma
file names
in
OS dot work
and inside the curly braces
we would write the path
for our folder
and we could simply copy the path of the
folder from here
it's showing cmd.exe right so I will go
back
and now I'll copy the path
and we'll paste it here and after the
curly braces I will just place a colon
and after that
I'll write
I will run a loop
it would be four
file name
in file names
we would be printing
OS dot path dot join
and inside the brackets we will pass the
directory name and the file name
okay
and now we'll just click on run you
could see that it's showing three files
that is finance underscore data.csv and
the IP ynb file that has been created by
us that is financial analysis and the
checkpoints that the Jupiter notebook
creates
and moving on we would be installing
some other modules and
first
I will tell you about numpy that it's an
open source and general purpose array
processing package it offers a
multi-dimensional array object with
outstanding speed as well as tools for
interacting with these arrays and about
pandas so pandas is an open source
Library designed primarily for working
quickly and intuitively with relational
or labeled data it offers a range of
data structures and procedures for
working with time series and numerical
data and this library is built on top of
the numpy library and it's quick and
offers its users exceptional performance
and productivity
and now we would be installing the matte
blue lip I've already installed so I
would be importing it matte plot lib
library and the seabun library
so for that I would write the command
and before importing I want to walk
through with this so OS dot work
function it generates the file names in
a directory Tree by working the tree
either top down or bottom up for each
directory in the two in the tree rooted
at the directory top it yields a three
double that is tractor path directory
name and the file name
so moving on now we'll install our
modules and that would be
C bone and matte blood lip
so
for C bone you could easily write the
command or you can search on the web how
to install it so for that the command
would be a pip install c-bone
so we would be
importing it
import C bone
and we'll be using the Allies here
as SNS
and now we would be using the pi plot
Library uh pipelout class of the
matplotlib library so for that you would
write the command
met.lib
and we'll be using the pipe load
and analyze for this as PLT
so we would be using these two libraries
also and we have run the command and it
has been executed successfully at it has
turned the number to three
now
if I tell you about C bone so C bone is
a library for making statistical
Graphics in Python and it builds on top
of matplotlib and integrates closely
with pandas data structures and C bone
helps you explore an entrance it helps
you understand your data its plotting
functions operate on data frames and
arrays containing whole data sets and
internally perform the necessary
semantic mapping and statistical
aggregation to produce information Proto
its data set oriented declarative API
lets you focus on what the different
elements of your plots mean rather than
on the details of how to draw them you
could easily draw them so you don't have
to think like how to draw them you could
just simply import this library and
start a functioning
now moving on we have Simone Library
also so it's a python data visualization
library that is based on matplotlip it
provides a high level interface for
drawing attractive and informative
statistical graphics
as now we have imported all the
libraries we can start with our project
and first thing we would be doing is we
would set the default style that is
would set the style function
that would be used for plot styling and
for that we would be using the allies of
C bone
and use the function set underscore
Style
and
will Mark as dark grid
we'll run this so it has been executed
successfully as you can see that the
number has turned out to before
so now
we would read the file that is a CSV
file and to read that we would declare a
variable and name it as DF and we'll use
the pandas library to read that and
write the command PD dot read
underscore CSV and inside the so I've
grown basis we would
write the path for the file
so we'll copy the path and in the
inverted commas we will paste the path
and at last we could just write the file
name
and the file name was Finance underscore
data
dot CSV
so here spelling is
Finance I have written the wrong
spelling for the file but it's okay
we'll use the same
fine and underscore data dot CSV
so now
we'll just run this
and you could see that our file has been
loaded so
as you can see our file is already
loaded and the reads underscore CSV
function it takes a path to a CSV file
and reads the data into a pandas data
frame object now we would be using the
DF dot add function
and run it
so what does this function do so it is
used to get the first n rows that is
this function Returns the first n rows
for the object based on position it is
useful for quickly testing if your
object has the right type of data in it
so it has
shown us that is the five
rows and mostly all the columns and it's
showing you that five rows cross 24
columns there are 24 columns here and it
has shown you all the columns now I will
drop some columns from the sheet and to
drop them we will write a command that
would be TF in which we have stored the
sheet
the DF variable
and inside that we will write
command that is drop and inside the
circular braces we would write the
columns we want to drop
and the name would be we will drop
columns that would be mutual funds
Equity Market
debentures government bonds fixed
deposits ppf gold
so we'll drop these columns
and to drop them we will write the name
of the columns in the Square braces
so first we'll write the name of the
mutual funds
let's Capital mutual funds Mutual
underscore funds sorry
which are underscore funds
and
then next we want to drop is equity
Market
for that we will write Equity Market
that is in inverted commas and Ms
capital for Equity Market
no debentures
and that to an inverted commas
uh
the next was government bonds fixed
deposits ppf and gold
okay so in inverted commas you write
comment bonds
and then it was ppf
and there was fixed deposits and there
was gold also
foreign
now we have listed all the columns that
we want to drop and now
we would set the axis equal to 1 that is
from the same axis x equal x is equal to
1 these all the columns would be
identified and they would be dropped and
they would be strong stored in the DF
variable
so for that all right
let me set the access
and access would be equal to
1 and we'll set in place
that would be equal to
true
okay so now
run this command
okay mean equal to equal to
okay so we will use
equal to zero
just find out
we will just restart it
now after restarting we will try to run
it
okay so there is
equal to cells
[Music]
too bad
X is equal to 1 and
place is equal to okay uh
circular bracket would be closed here
yeah
our Command has been executed
successfully as you can see in the
Square braces we have a number eight
that means the command has been
successfully executed and we have
dropped these columns and now moving on
we'll use the replace function that
would be the pandas replace function and
we will replace all the empty columns
with NN that is node a number value and
for that we'll write a command DF that
is TF equal to DF dot replace
and inside
we will write command
let's run dolo
and
this would be enclosed in the inverted
commas
and a comb afterwards
and NP Dot N A N what we want and then
set regex that is equal to
true
and now if we run this it has been
executed successfully and the replace
function it replaces all the occurrence
of matched pattern in the string and a
regular expression that is rejects we
have used here that is equal to true
it's a sequence of characters that
Define a search pattern and filter rows
is pandas like to filter rows in pandas
by regex we can use the string dot match
method
now moving on
here we would start with the floating
and we'll use the C bone
and
we will draw our first plot that would
be the bar plot only
and for that would
we will use count dot function
count plot
and we'll set the x parameter
as gender
you could see in the sheet gender where
we are setting it as X
and the next thing we would set would be
data that is we would take the data from
the variable DF in which we have stored
the file
that is the CSV file and line width
for the plot and we will set it as
three
and then we'll set the palette
and that would be equal to
set to
and then we'll set the edge color
and that would be black
and after that we would use the function
that would be PLT dot show
and we'll run the command
as you can see that we have set the x
parameter as gender and count so it's
showing how many males and females are
investing at
Nick what are the numbers in this sheet
how many males are investing and how
many females are investing
so moving on
and first if we see
in here so we have used the count plot
function that is the method used to show
the counts of observation in each
categorial bin using bars and we have
set the x that is the parameter that
takes names of variables in data or
vector data or optional or optional
inputs that is used for plotting long
form data and we have used palette that
takes the value of the palette and it is
mostly used to show the Hue variable and
what is U here U is the parameter that
specifies the column name
and we have set the data is equal to DF
that is the parameter that defines the
data frame that we would like to take
for the representation for instance data
can be an array and moving on
we will draw another plot
using the C bone only and the count plot
function
so sns.count plot and inside we will
pass X parameter equal to H
and then we'll pass the data that would
be equal to DF and set the palette
that would be equal to
set 3
and then we'll set line width
that is equal to 2 and then we'll set
the edge color
of the
plot that is the bar graph
we will set the edge color
that would be black
and now we will run this
you could see
that it has X level s h and y level as
count
that is at how many age men and women
both combine are investing at the age of
21
to women or men like two people we would
say we won't
make it consideration as gender here so
we are just counting how many people are
investing at which age
so
moving on
now we'll move to another plot and
draw something related to age only
and you could also use plt.show to
just get your
output
if you're right here plt.show
it will give you the same output and
here now it's not showing the x-axis and
y axis you could easily see here
but it's defining
now moving on
now we'll draw a figure and using the
matplotlip and here we will be using two
plots
and I would like you would understand
with
this only first we will draw it and then
I will explain what I want to show you
so first we will use the Metro clip
allies that would be PLT dot figure and
inside we are passing fig size that
would be equal to
18 comma six
and after that I would be using the
subplot that is
we would be drawing two plots here and
for one subplot
LT dot subplot inside we would pass the
parameters for this upload
the first we have defined the figure
size the whole figure and inside there
would be two plots and inside those
plots what would be the size for one
plot so that would be defined by PLT dot
subplot
and now
sns.count plot
we would
draw count plot here and inside we will
pass the X parameter
that is equal to DF and inside we will
pass the column that would be gender
and
here we will set the view
that is equal to DF
and inside the bracket that is a square
bracket
you would write the
investment Avenues
that
who will are investing
and with their underscore yeah they will
underscore investment underscore
Avenues
and now we have set the view here
and now we'll set the palette
to set the palette
we would set the palette as summer
and after setting the palette we'll set
the line width
for the upload that is the bar and would
say test three and after that we'll set
the edge color
and Edge color would be equal to
White
and now we'll give the title to this
upload only this upload and for that we
would write a command PLT dot title
and inside this title
you would write
investment
venue
and after that
we will draw another subplot that would
be PLT Dot
subplot and
for that we will Define the parameters
that would mean comma 2 comma 1
2
and we'll use
sns.count plot
and inside let's set the x parameter
that would be DF and inside the square
brackets we define gender
and set the Hue that would be equal to
DF
then inside
you would
write for the stock market
foreign
stock market
and
now we'll set the palette
and we'll set the palette as
hot only
now after setting the palette we would
set the line width
then went through the plot that would be
equal to 3 and after line width we would
set Edge color
that would be equal to White
and after that we would set the title
for it
PLT Dot
title
and site title we would set it as
stock market
and use the function PLT Dot
show
to show both the graphs now we'll run
this command
Market
[Music]
so we'll check
okay americ
so we have the column name here MLK
so use the same
and run it
so you could see there are two subplots
and they are inside the figure that is
of the value 18 comma 6 and here we have
gender and count that is investment
Revenue
who all are investing
and here we have who all are investing
in the stock market and according to the
gender
like in females how many are
investing in stock market they are
indicated by red color and those who are
not investing they are indicated by
yellow color and same with the men
and if you see we have used a big size
here that is a tuple of the width and
height of the figure in inches
and we have set the inches here and
subplot that means groups of axes that
can exist in a single matplotlip figure
and subplots function is the mat that is
stored in the matplotlib library and
helps in creating multiple layouts of
sub loads and it provides control over
all the individual plots that are
created
and we have created that
now moving on we will create another
account plot using the C bone and for
that we'll write the command sns.count
plot
and inside will pass the X parameter
that would be equal to DF and
inside would pass Factor
check with
a sheet
that is the factor so we will pass this
and set the palette for it and line
width and Edge color and we'll draw the
account plot so the factor is
how the people are
investing like they are looking for
returns or they are investing for
locking period so that their investment
could be stored for a longer period of
time or they're risking their investment
to have some more interests or more
returns
so for that would be drawing the account
plot and we have set x equal to factor
and now we'll set the pallet
so we'll set the palette equal to cool
home
and now we will set line width
that would be equal to 2
and now we'll set the edge color
that would be equal to
black
and we'll use the function PLT dot show
so just run this command and you could
see that we have a subploter node
subplot but a plot and that is a bar
plot
and you could see how many people are
just for returns that is 25 and we have
login period and who are risking their
investment
you could see the counter using this
count plot and now moving on
we will use matplotlib and
have another figure
and
here we will be having our plot that is
for purpose like which purpose
which purpose the people are investing
if you could see the purpose here that
is for wealth savings
for which purpose they are investing
wealth creation or just savings for
future
or returns
so we'll create a plot here and for that
we'll use
matplotlip
and we will write the command PLT dot
figure
and inside we would set the figure size
that would be equal to 16 comma 8
and after that
you would set sns.
Point plot
and that is we would be pointing the
plots and set the x parameter as purpose
and Y parameter that would be equal to H
and now we'll set the data
that is equal to DF
and now we will
have the line style as you'll see this
would be a different plot here
and we'll set the line Style with this
style and now we'll set cap size that
would be equal to 3
node 3 that would be 0.3
and after setting the cap size we'll set
the color
and we'll set the color as blue
now we'll write the command PLT Dot
show
and run the command for you guys
so we got an error that is figure size
and that would be equal to node equal to
equal to
now we'll run this again
and we got Point plot quote and line
Style
okay we have
line style and that would be line styles
yeah we got our output
that is you can see this graph this is
for just having the purpose and seeing
the IH what would be the median age for
what purpose like who are investing for
wealth creation what is the median age
you can see here for saying for future
purpose you can see the median age and
for returns purpose you can have the
median age
we have used the line Styles here that
is line style is used for each of the
Hue levels that is for each of the
column levels and we've set the cap size
that is the width of the caps on error
bars and that we have set as 0.3
now moving on
we will
create another plot and that would be
our last plot only
so for that we would
be having
the Metro clip Library only and would
set
figure and here we would be having two
subplots
so first we will Define the figure size
that would be fixed size
and that is equal to 18 comma 6
and now
we would use the subplot function
PLT dots subplot
and we would Define the parameters for
subplot
and now we'll use C bone sns.
use the count plot function
to have upload and here we will pass you
that would be setting as
gender
and now we'll set the x parameter
that will set us
duration forward duration people are
no but we will have the gender here
so
forward duration gender is
each gender is investing
now we'll set the palette
and duration that would mean inverted
commas
now inside the palette
that is pellet equal to
where it is you could see the design of
the plot that it would be where it is
and after that would set the line width
and that would be equal to
after setting the line width we would
set the edge color
that would be equal to Black
and after that you would set the
title of this subplot
and would set the title as duration
and now you would have another subplot
for that
subplot
you would write the command PLT dot
subplot and inside will pass the
parameters for this subplot that is 1
comma 2 comma 2
and now we would use the count plot
and inside the count plot will pass you
and that is equal to
DF
and inside would pass
gender
and that would pass the X parameter that
is
investment monitor
we could see in the
sheet
that is investment monitor
oh sorry like how these genders are
investing they are investing monthly
weekly or daily
so I would see that in
this upload
and
we are passing the investment monitor as
the X parameter
so
we'll pass it investment
underscore monitor
and after the X variable we'll set the
palette
and the palette would set as seismic
you could see what seismic is when you
will see the plot
and you could use after if you liked
else you could use another palette and
now we will set the line width
and that would be equal to 2
and after that we would set the edge
color
that would be black for this
and now we'll give the title to this
upload and
we will give the title
by using the command PLT dot title and
in the inverted commas you will write
investment monitoring
and after that we'll write the command
PLT dot show
and run the command
and we put an error that is investment
monitor so we'll see invest underscore
monitor it's not investment monitor
so title is okay yeah
investors commentator
and run it
and you can see uh both the subplots
have been displayed here the first is
duration and it's against the counter
and you could see the genders that is
female and male that is how males and
females are investing the investment for
what time period that is one two three
duration for more than five years for
three to five years and for less than
one year and if you see investment
monitoring that how genders are
investing the amount that is how they
are investing monthly what numbers
like you can see that the blue colors
indicate female invest monthly and that
would be in the range
10.0 to 12.5 that is around 11 and if
you see men they are above 17.5 and same
as weekly and daily
and with that we have come to the end of
this session
and I have insightful for you guys
if you are aiming to get certified in
Python Programming and want to build a
python software development career in
that case you can check this python
certification course by simcleaner which
will open the doors for your career
growth and to find the details you can
check in the description box below I
will provide the link for this and link
for the CSV file and link for the ipy NB
file that is the Jupiter notebook file
and I hope this session holds
interesting and informative if you liked
it please let us know in the comment
section below and also do subscribe for
more from Simply learn thank you
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here